since you're one of the first
feature-length films is that right to do
equity crowdfunding we're the first
feature-length narrative film on the
United States to do equity crowdfunding
okay and it sounds like you've done a
lot of research you and your team so if
you were to sit down and advise someone
else that wants to do the same what are
some top five things that they should be
aware of right away if you're allowed to
talk about that now I know they're sure
within the guidelines of what you can
talk about no I can absolutely I can
talk about that it's um that's a great
question because that's a question I
would love to her the answers to about
six months ago was I'm working on this
the first thing you need to know is it's
a ton of paperwork it's like doing your
taxes times a hundred there's a counting
paperwork legal paperwork you can hire
people to do this or you can do it
yourself okay but there are a few things
where you do have to have an actual
lawyer at least look it over because
it's an investment this is a serious
thing you know people are trusting you
with their money and you're saying hey
if you invest in our company we're going
to make money and we're going to give
you more money back so you make a profit
that's what you're saying to these
people that's a serious thing you know
and people are show business we're
creative okay
we're creative people we like to tell
stories we like to write we like to act
we like to direct them there that we're
not accountants okay if we want to be an
accountant we be doing that you know
we're not lawyers or we'd be doing that
yes so you have to embrace the fact
number one that there's a lot of
paperwork and you're going to be doing a
lot of jobs that are not fun and
creative like acting writing and
directing is okay so you have to embrace
that and do these chores you can hire
people to do it you can spend about ten
thousand dollars and have other
professionals do all that paperwork and
all that stuff for you or maybe like
five to ten depending on exactly how
much money you're raising the more money
you want to raise you can raise up to a
million dollars under the regulation
crowdfunding rules okay you can hire
people for five to ten thousand dollars
to do all that stuff for you
okay and then the second thing is have a
great video it's really important
Kickstarter campaign yep you have to
have a great video that gets people
excited okay the third thing which I
found out from I emailed people who had
done successful campaigns of people who
had a biotech company an electronics
company food company completely
different from the movie business but
email they said hi I'm going to do this
to have any advice to my surprise they
wrote back generously told me a lot of
things and all these people from these
you know pretty uh you know pretty
different companies they're not you know
the biotech and things like that they
said that the vast majority of their
investors invested for emotional reasons
for because they liked the people they
saw in the video who are going to be
having their money than running the
company because they got a good feeling
for me he said eighty to ninety percent
of investors said that that's why they
invested then only about ten or twenty
percent or you know analytical
spreadsheet kind of people who drilled
down into all the numbers and everything
and invested for those reason ask
questions about you know your ROI and
you're this and you're that that was a
smaller percentage of people but
substantial they still put a good amount
of money and so all these like companies
that were in a formal and strict and not
like fine and chauvinist
said it's emotional so I thought wow
because and it made sense to me and I
thought well I'm in show business if I
can't make if I can't make a plea that
shows people how we feel about doing
this so that was the other big thing you
said five s three things so you want one
five things oh so much pressure so much
pressure oh the other thing is is your
it's going to take over your life it's
this is 12 14 16 hour days online doing
social media spreading the word it's
non-stop you have to have it least two
people on your team full-time
we hired a Facebook ad team people who
are doing the Facebook ads and putting
those out because we didn't have time to
do that
we hired consultants who has consulted
on other campaigns like ours to tell us
what to do so we could learn all this
stuff so you need a team of people
that's that's the other thing that's
four things so I gotta come up with the
five I actually have to follow up yes so
then we can actually almost make it
seven okay but so the follow-up is you
said there's a team of people that maybe
you could pay around five to ten
thousand dollars to do some of this
paperwork and all what what's the name
of that Job Description like who what
what type of if we're searching for
those companies what are we looking for
what's the name of it
oh well there's a three things you can
you can search online for regulation
crowdfunding consultants you can find
firms who do that there are some who you
can come to them and say I have this
product or a movie say I want to raise
the money and they say fine
you pay us X amount of dollars we'll do
all the paperwork so all you have to do
is provide us with some information sign
your name I will do all the ads with it
you know and they cost more money okay
and they frequently will take a portion
of your company you know 5% 6% of your
company as part of their fee in addition
to you paying them upfront Oh
interesting
you know they're they become business
partners with you in it yes their
investors okay yeah but you're paying
them we're paying them in money and
you're paying them in stock for your
company you can find you can find those
companies around and you can see what
companies they successfully raise money
for okay that's more turnkey system or
you can just hire an accountant your CPA
and an attorney who's specializes in
this field and again if you search
regulation crowdfunding attorney you
will find people to specialize in this
and I thought it turns a pretty good if
you're the county attorney and they
don't really know how to do this they'll
turn you on to somebody who does so you
can cut the money in fact that you're
spending upfront by just hiring them for
very specific tasks now what are those
tasks if you need to do what is all this
paperwork the great resource for that
is the portal they call these portals
these are SEC registered websites
there's only 26 of them as of this
moment as a May 2017 and they have to be
registered with the SEC and you have to
run your campaign through them through
one of them they're like Kickstarter but
instead of Kickstarter rewards based
it's a investment base okay you go to
these portals and there are the three
top ones right now our start engine
which is what we're on we funder and
micro ventures those are the top three
right now now that they have the track
record you go to those sites and they
have a lot of great information you know
a fact that tells you what you need to
know if you want to raise money this way
okay so you can find that out it's a lot
of research because you know it's it's
online it's like three months just to
get to the point where you can launch
the campaign interesting three months of
solid work and then with hiring the
attorney
it sounds like are you just hiring them
for looking over the launching of the
campaign making sure the wording
everything is correct and again if I'm
overstepping my bounds the question okay
so so it's just sort of like you let
them know what needs to be done and then
they sort of give you their hourly rate
and then you're done once the campaign
is launched or are they on retainer and
you're following up with them throughout
the campaign it depends on what you need
them for
there are several firms that will do it
for a flat rate let's say if you pay as
$5,000 we will do all the paperwork all
the legal paperwork to get you launched
and then a couple of follow-ups up for
example when we had our press release
that we issued to the press to talk
about the movie I ran that by the
attorney to make sure that we didn't
violate any of the what they call
communication guidelines from the SEC to
make sure that we didn't say anything
for example you can't say if you invest
in our company you'll make a billion
dollars but because
that's the promise that the SEC says gee
you're not likely to have that come true
are you and so you can't you can't what
personal you couldn't you can't lie to
the public that's just wrong anyway but
you can't over-promised in your
excitement you can't say that's going to
be the best movie ever you know and so
you can't really say that according to
the SEC if you can say hey this is our
team we have an Oscar we have four Emmys
we know what we're doing and we're
making this movie that you can say
because it's true it's a fact
so I ran all that stuff by the lawyer
and to make sure that we weren't being
over enthusiastic we where we were fine
so that's how you use a lawyer after
you've lodged but all the other lawyer
work is getting ready for the launch and
the months before the launch because you
have to fill out a lot of things and we
by the way let's just campaign yes you
see does a background check for you I've
never had a background check done before
I felt so naughty
yeah sadly I'm not that interesting so I
passed the background check but yeah but
everybody who does the campaign on these
portals who was doing equity
crowdfunding they've gone through
background checks to make sure that
right nothing Shady why is no securities
fraud or anything like that right so
then with the Facebook ads anything you
can recommend because we've heard that
for some people they work very well and
I'm wondering if there are certain
strategies with Facebook ads that you
could recommend if that's within the
guidelines yeah the Facebook ads have
done well for us but it's been a real
learning curve I did not know about this
whole world of data that Facebook had I
mean I heard about it write about it eh
use Facebook but until I started
purchasing ads when you buy an ad
Facebook you can say what audience it is
you can say age you can say male/female
you can say they're interested in this
they're interested in that and Facebook
will tell you exactly how many thousands
or millions of people fit the criteria
and you can really fine-tune the
audience you can have your ads run
within a hundred miles of Charlotte
North Carolina only if you want you can
do amazing fine-tuning of things and so
it took a while for us to find
tune the people who would want to invest
in a Christmas movie and once you reach
them they're like oh that's great but if
you're somebody who you know only likes
horror movies they're they're not
interested so Facebook Ads can be very
effective and there are a million
consultants who would be happy to work
with you to help fine-tune these ads and
they'll run like 20 different ads that
are like subtly different really
different and then they measure exactly
how well it does so then they can you
can just narrow it down and find out you
know I think of it as when you when you
go in a sitcom when you're shooting a
live sitcom with a live audience
you do the scene and you see how the
audience reacts and if they didn't laugh
enough in certain places the writers
quickly write new jobs so they have
other jokes already and they give it to
the actors they do the scene again and
change two or three or four or five of
the jokes in the scene and see if the
audience laughs better so it's a similar
process to doing Facebook as you
fine-tune it until the resonate so the
audience just like you know making that
live audience laughs now did you work
with a consultant or you've done all
this on your own with your team in terms
of purchasing the ads looking at the
metrics and things like that I did it
all myself for the first couple of weeks
because I thought it was interesting and
then I realized that I learned enough to
know what I don't know
oh I handed it off to people who do know
who live and breathe this sort of thing
so they can get results more quickly you
know it's like I mean hey you could you
could you know you could run the camera
and the sound and direct and write the
whole movie but why don't you hand off
that camera and that's sound you know
somebody who does that for a living so
okay so you knew what your strengths for
and you knew when because they say
successful people always ask for help so
it sounds like that's good you don't
have to do everything yourself but I'm
glad I did do it for a couple of weeks
because now I understand what the heck
they're talking about that's when they
talk about if they learn things like
click-through rates cost per click every
time somebody clicks on your ad in
facebook
you pay facebook so I just learned all
this amazing stuff
very cool yeah it's good that you know
what you're you know getting into but in
terms of having someone else fine-tune
it sounds like you wanted them to do it
nice
now with this campaign is this an
all-or-nothing campaign no we've reached
our minimum so once you reach the
minimum you know you're good to go we
reach actually 700 percent of our men um
oh wow yeah seven weeks so it's uh we'll
have a link below this video and on the
site so people can go to it and they can
see more what you're talking about so we
don't overstuff anything so
you